Hi. Hi. It's Smartless, everybody. You want to go around and introduce yourselves? We haven't done it in a long time. We haven't. Yeah, go ahead. I'm Sean Hay.
I'm Sean Hayes. I'm Will Arnett. And I'm Jason Vae. What's your porn name, Sean? Middle name and street you grew up on. Patrick Valley. Patrick Valley. That's actually pretty good.
That's pretty porny. JB, what about you? It is porny. Kent Emerson. Kent Emerson. That's a good one. That's a good one. That's a good one.
That's a good one. That's a good one. That's a good one. Patrick Valley. Patrick Valley. That's actually pretty good. That's pretty porny. JB, what about you? It is porny. Kent Emerson. No way. Sounds like he's got a strong mustache, right? Guess what?
Mine is Emerson Edgar. Oh! Oh my gosh. Wow, did you guys do a porn together? Are we gonna do porn together? Yeah. Let's do it after an all new smart list. Okay.
Smart List. Sean, when we had dinner Saturday night, all of us at our friend's house in New York. We did. And then at a certain point, Downey was wearing that shirt, that t-shirt that he sort of wore for JB. And he said, I want to give it to you. And he said, okay, so let's switch now. So all of a sudden in the middle of this dinner party, JB and Downey stand up and they go
tarps off and switch. I didn't see that. Yeah, a little top swap. Wait, but you had a Sex Pistols t-shirt on. Right, that was his, he gave it to me. Downey walked in with that. Oh, I thought that's what you showed up with. No, I was just in a generic blue tee, a nice tee.
Sure. And I said, you know what? Who was I? Robert, we're looking for beautiful vintage rock T-shirts for this idiot character I'm playing. And man, that looks like a good one. And he had the sex pistols on? Yeah, and he goes, oh yeah, I paid a lot of money for this.
And he told me the number, I was like, good lord. And he said, you want it? For a T-shirt? He paid a lot of money for a T-shirt? Oh, buddy. I said, yeah, I want it. He goes, well here, let paid a lot of money for a t-shirt? Oh buddy. I said, yeah I want it. He goes, well here, let's step over here and I'll give it to you.
I said, no, you're what? And then he said, yeah, yeah, no. I said, well we don't need to step anywhere. Let's just do it right here. Jason. So we just, a little top swap and now I'm going to work it into the show but we're trying to get clearance on Sex Pistols
and if we don't get clearance on it then I'm just gonna work it into the show, but we're trying to get clearance on Sex Pistols. And if we don't get clearance on it, then I'm just gonna put it in my wardrobe, you know, my closet at home. Wait for Danny to forget. Yes, but I can get you a thousand of those for $5. You can get me a thousand t-shirts for $5? Oh, like vintage old, like 70s, 80s, 90s bands. Where are you getting these from?
You just get them online. Oh, okay. Or in vintage shops. I just went, I went vintage shopping with Franny yesterday because she wanted to do some shopping here in New York. And while she was looking at her stuff, I went looking at the old rock t-shirts there in this incredible store called Metropolis down on Broadway.
And God, they got a great site. And I bought five great old rock concert t-shirts and man, they're expensive. You know, you should have asked, you know Alessandra had a t-shirt business, this is not a bit, for years. Really? Yeah, she has like a warehouse full of
incredible vintage tees that she procured over the years. But boxes upon boxes upon boxes. Why is she holding onto them? Why does she sell them to places like Trump? It was hard for her to, well, because they don't do the business anymore, so they got to figure out what they're going to do with the... Assets. With the stock. Yeah, yeah.
Well, I can take a lot of that off her hands. Yeah, same. Me and Sean will help her out. As long as it's in New York, you can take a look at it. Great. Where is she at? Is she still here? She is. Did she come back with you? No, she is. She's there. I'll tell her to call you after.
Great. JB, I don't know if you know this, Sean's had two hours sleep, he had another AFib in the middle of the night, true story. I just got home. And had to go to Mount Sinai. Just got home an hour ago. Did you OD on gummies?
No. So now I don't, you know what I did? What'd you do? You guys are gonna laugh. I got it. I'm not. Did they have a sale on butter pecan ice cream? What happened?
And you went crazy? I was walking down the street and I hailed a cab and I ran to get the cab and it just triggered it. You can't run? Okay, what you need is a nice aerobics class, I think is what I'm figuring out. No, I'm gonna get the ablation where they go in and they fry a little part of your heart out.
You've heard what that is, right? No, I've also heard about just like a step class, or a stationary bike. When do you work on your fucking endurance? No, I have endurance. I should clearly not. You're running after a cab and you end up in the hospital. I know. But Sean, you should go into your pantry with a flamethrower and do an ablation on all the
food that's in there. Listen, hey, Glass House, let's not talk about pantries. Yeah. Okay? JB loves coming into my pantry. It's so, but here's what happens is he, every single time he comes in, he goes in, he goes in the pantry and then comes out and he's like,
you got a lot of stuff, what are you gonna eat? As he's stuffing his stupid fat face. Did I ever show you the picture I took of your freezer, or sorry, your ice cream fridge? Yes, I love it. So you got one side with soda and food, and then the other side, which is supposed to be a freezer, is just basically like a repository for ice cream.
Yeah. It's all that sweet, sweet, sweet McConnell ice cream, which I adore, and I like Haagen-Dazs too. Here comes more. Haagen-Dazs is the best. Haagen-Dazs, I'll probably... Haagen hug and does I'll hug you guys looking for free ice cream I'm just gonna sorry I'm gonna put a little wet I'm gonna put an address a link they can click on at the end Jay
You know why I love hog and eyes vanilla ice cream because it's only milk eggs cream and sugar and that's it and Vanilla sometimes you just pour those ingredients in your mouth right stick your head in the freezer Just make it a little mouthwash with pour those ingredients in your mouth, right, and they stick your head in the freezer. Just make it in your mouth. And do a little mouth wash with them. Make it in your mouth, pour it in, they stick your head in. Oh god, Jason's busy over there. I'm lacing my new shoes.
So, Franny, maple, Franny got me into a t-shirt addiction. Maple's got me into really expensive tennis shoes. Yeah, those are those. And now I can't stop. Yeah. They made a difference? In my, I don't know, they more comfortable or? No, they just, they make me feel pretty, you know? Okay, well you look pretty.
Guys, I wanna get back to the funny guy who's like waiting for us, he's the best. I'm excited for this. He's clearly a patient guy too. Yes, and he makes me laugh, sorry. He's a fellow podcaster and all-around funny guy. At age five, he asked his parents if he could change his name, and they said yes.
I'd consider him part of my own personal SNL Hall of Fame, mastering some of my favorite impressions of all time. And though he's a standalone talent, his comedy work usually comes as a package deal of three. Together, do you know who it is yet? No. Together with his comedy trio, he helped put YouTube on the map
with his hilarious star-studded music videos in the early 2000s. It's my comedy friend, Andy Samberg. Andy Samberg, yep. Andy Samberg! Yes! Andy. Yeah.
Woo! God damn, that's so over. This is so relaxed. This is incredibly overdue. I know. How have you, have you been ducking us? Have we not been able to make your deal? What is it?
What's happening? Yeah, Ryder. Uh-huh, got it. Are you at a massage place right now with the screen behind you? Yes. Yeah. Are you getting it?
Are you getting the massage? He said I'm gonna do your podcast but I'm doing one word answer. Yeah. Wait, wait, can I just say that I saw, so Andy knows what I'm about to say, which is I saw him like two weeks ago. Oh really?
We were out and he goes, hey, hey idiot, I'm coming to do your stupid podcast. Oh, so you're retelling. This is a major Rashomon. That's pretty true, isn't it? There's almost word for word. You said something like- No, I said hey, first off, hadn't seen you in years.
I know. Right? Yeah. Hey, I'm about to be on your very successful podcast. That's literally what I said. And you went, no! You're not supposed to tell me! And stormed off.
It does sound like this. Going like this, la la la la, holding his ears, la la la la. And I was like, all right, you have a Going like this, la la la la, holding his head, la la la. And I was like, all right, you have a foot on me first off, very intimidating. It does happen quite a bit. And then I spent the rest of the night at the Vanity Fair party, like, sulking
because I ruined your night. You were there, I didn't see you there. I was there. I saw you guys all together promoting the show. Sean, you left at 6.45, so. I put some eyes on you there. Andy, we dressed almost exactly the same, although I'm not wearing my hoodie, but baseball hat.
You can grab it. We got time, right? It's a podcast. It's a great podcast. So Andy, thank you for coming on today. I was really excited about you coming. And I, well, first of all, I didn't know you changed your name. I thought you were always Andy.
What was it before? Sean, hi. Nice to see you. Good to see you too. When I was five, I changed my name to Andy from David. My middle name, it was my first name was David and then. And we got it. Your middle name was Annie.
I mean my mom was just cool about it is basically the short version of the story. Why do you hate David so much? What's wrong with David? I don't know, I just felt like an Andy is the... Are you serious? I get kind of. I knew you were an Andy.
But honestly, like when you look at me, the first name you think personality-wise, obviously is Adam, that's what everyone calls me on accident. But then... Right. Then after that, obviously, is Adam. That's what everyone calls me on accident. But then, then after that, Andy A. McMatches. Adam Sandberg and Justin Bateman. He gets Justin all day.
I got another one yesterday. Do you really? Are you serious? By the way, everyone has someone that they get the name of that person for. And I always think you get big enough and it stops. But then everyone I talk to has someone. No, I'm nowhere near it.
I get the, I get the, I loved you on SNL, and I'm like, never on it. And then they're like, and I figured like, they've got me confused, and I've talked about with like, either like, Sudeikis me forte, just kind of middle-aged white dude. And they just go, you're- I bet it's forte, cause you're both Wills.
Maybe. You know what, the other day I was in the doctor's office like a couple months ago, and I'm walking out and this guy in the waiting room goes, hey, where are the other two and a half guys? Oh no, you're John Cryer. I'm like, I thought they met Jason and Will, and I got to the elevator and I was like. They thought you were Angus, the kid from doing that.
All grown up. I thought it was gonna be like, Jason and Will, and one of them is notorious for having a massive wang. Yeah, that's it. Old 50 pound unit. Yeah. That's pretty good. That's how long it took me to bring up dicks.
Wait, so let's talk about. I'm all ears. What if you hit a stopwatch as soon as you said it? That's pretty good. That's how long it took me to bring up dicks. Wait, so let's talk about... I'm all ears. What if you hit a stopwatch as soon as you set it? In my defense, I was on ice for a while while you guys chatted about t-shirts and stuff. So I count that time as my preamble time. Hey, can you believe? I mean, this is the kind of talk on a hit podcast. Can I... Wait. can I embarrass myself early?
Andy, you're a fella. I don't know well. We never really crossed paths. I know precisely the, the times we have because, because I've, I think I've always wanted to be your friend and I just never would never cross this path. And you, both these guys know that that's a big deal because I don't really have a lot of friends. But I've targeted you.
And I feel like we'd be great together. I completely agree and I feel the same. This is nice. It's thrilling to have you. Here's the one thing. If you could just quiet down, Will. Sorry, Will, we're talking, dude. Just give us one second.
Sean, go take a break. I was gonna use your wheels. Yeah. But no Will, we're talking, dude. Just give us one second. Sean, go take a break. Use your wheels. Yeah, but no, I really like the cut of your jib, huh? Likewise and ditto, thank you, first off. All right, I like that you're in Los Angeles. That increases our odds. That's true. I think probably your kids are older than mine,
so that decreases our odds. That's true, although mine can train yours. I pretty much only see people with kids my age at this point. But Jason, you're in luck because we're going to get to know Andy right now. Oh my God, you're right. And we're going to start at the beginning. I don't know, Sean, if you've ever listened to our podcast, but we don't really, we're not known for fucking good questions.
We don't like the guest talking much at all. Letting our guest talk a ton. So listen back to your parts. So yeah, so Andy, you take a five. You take a five. That's fine. Can I just say, can I just say, Andy? Yes, what?
I know you a little bit. Probably better than the other two guys from over the years. Yeah, we've hung out a lot. And we have hung out a lot over the years, and a lot lot, and then Andy was also, first of all, JB, you know this, so that you don't embarrass yourself You know that Andy was in a rest of development Oh what?
It was a blip Wait blip. How I got I believe it's how I got in the sag We want and we talked about it on the DVD extras of season two as well. That's how long I didn't even know there were DVD extras You were participating in it. Did you know you were in the show? What did I, tell me the name of the show one more time. So it was season two and I had just seen Andy, Andy and Kiva and Yoruba had just done,
the Lonely Island Boys as they're known, had just done a pilot called Awesome Town that was produced by Phil Lord and Chris Miller. I wanna see that. Right, Andy? Yes. And it was really good. It was really for Fox. It was a sketch comedy, sort of variety... I don't even know how to describe it.
Special. Before SNL? Yes, pre... Yeah, yeah. The year before. What year was that, Andy, that you guys did that? Do you remember? Like... 2004.
2004. It was so funny. And I was like, oh my God, I was just obsessed with that pilot. These guys are fucking awesome. Yeah, I wanna know about that Andy. So like the lonely, the lonely guy's like. Well hang on, no wait, I wanna know what fucking episode
he was in in Arrested Development. Where was I? Now don't tell me I was in the scene with him. Andy, go. No. I think it was me and Cross, right Will? Yeah, it was you and Cross. Which, first off, Arrested Development was our favorite show.
Like me, Keev, and Yoram sat around talking about it. It was how it was like, this is the first time ever on American television that comedy has been allowed to move this fast and be this funny and every single person on it destroys. British Office was our inspiration. Or at least me and Will. Which showed, but like, it felt super different. And we were super big fans of Mr. Show also.
So like the cross-pollination of those things was making our brains explode. So I was not in SAG. Really? I was doing standup and we were shooting our own videos and sort of like trying to cobble it together. And then I got the call to come do this like One line I think I was an usher at blue man group No way, and it was the like next next week on the show thing
That's not real right and it was me talking across. I think I had one line Were you in blue man makeup cross? No, no, I don't think I was no I you were like, yeah, you were like in an Usher's outfit or something. Yeah, and my hair was just massive. Seth Meyers said when he first met me, it looked like my hair was trying to eat my head. Man, I gotta, Willie, remember how we used to sit and watch the show, we'd watch them
when they were on on Sundays, right? We'd sit there like a couple of newbies, just like, here comes our show, our show's coming on, and we'd watch it, and then we'd sit there like a couple of newbies just like, here comes our show, our show's coming on and we'd watch it and then we'd go outside for smokes during the commercial breaks and then we'd go back in and then we'd check online to see what the comments were and then the next morning what the ratings were. Television without, TV without pity. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Like a message board and up at your old house. Yeah, yeah, I do remember that and I remember, you know what, yesterday I was going through some of my stuff upstairs, and I found the New York Times TV Remember they used to put up like this or the New York Times TV guy You know what's coming up in the week and whatever yeah, and Arrested Development was on the cover. It was November of 2003 and they didn't really know what to make it nobody they're like this is Amy who knows and Anyway, I'm just what show you guys. What show are you guys talking about? It's called The Rest of the Moment. Anyway, so Andy comes and does that.
And then, so that was like 2004, that was the spring of 2005. Mary Lou Henner on the podcast. Well, crazy, with the dates. Cause it was like one of the last episodes of that second season. So that was like 2005. And then when was it because it was like one of one of the last episodes of that second season So that was like 2005 and then when was it that SN how did it? How did SNL happen you guys had done the pilot that did not get picked up by Fox?
Yes, and then we tried to sell it around town We thought for sure we were gonna get snagged by like MTV 2 or something. Yeah, no dice And we were like we're cooked that was our shot And we were like, we're cooked. That was our shot. And we were writing together splitting a single writing check, working on the MTV Movie Awards for the second year. The three of you? Yeah. Wow.
And the first year we wrote for it, it was Lindsay Lohan. And then the second year we did it, it was Fallon. And so Fallon came in hosting and he brought all the SNL people with him and we just hung out with them basically for three or four straight weeks and loved them and hit it off. And Higgins and Shoemaker were there who were, one is still a big producer there and the other now runs Seth's show,
but they were high up there. And Jimmy was obviously- Steve Higgins and Mike Shoemaker. The SNL guy. And so we, me, K Yoram, and some others were responsible for writing a few of the like pre-tapes where you put the host in the movies from that year. Right.
And we wrote a Star Wars one and a Batman one that both got picked. So we were just hanging out with everyone on set, pitching jokes, and they were like, hey, these guys seem like they love comedy a lot. In a way that, you know, you sometimes are shocked to realize that people don't. And did they invite you to audition?
Or did they just say, we've seen enough, let's make them writers? Invited to audition. I had done stand-up at that point for six or seven years, on and off, starting in college. And I'd been on Premium Blend on Comedy Central, which was a thing. And then we had our pilot. I didn't think I knew and I'd been on Premium Blend on Comedy Central, which was a thing. And then we had our pilot.
I didn't think I knew that, that you'd been doing standup before that. Yes. I wouldn't say I was like, H-O-T in the biz, but. Yeah, H-O-T. I was like, I was at the edge of it though. Like I had just gotten to the point where I went in for the meeting at the Improv on Melrose
to be like, hey, you could come start doing real spots. Wow. Just for my sister Tracy, lives in Wisconsin, just a little context. And I didn't know this until I started reading about you that the three, so you started this little comedy troupe which is now also a production company called The Lonely Island.
And it's three of your friends. I did not know this that you met an eighth grade. Yeah, well, Keev and Yoram's seventh grade. That's crazy, seventh grade. And so, and then, so when you got hired on SNL, so you guys had been friends for all those years, and then when you get hired on SNL, they hire all three of you at the same time.
That's what I couldn't understand, is like, but Andy was on, oh, they were, oh, I see, so they wrote. Did all three of you audition to be performers, or were they just like, we just want to be writers, you can be the performer? I auditioned first, and it went pretty good. And they said, we want you to come back. And then at that time, they asked Keev and Yoram
if they also wanted to audition. And so Yoram did, and Akiva said, no, I don't want to be on camera. And then the three of us also submitted a writing packet on behalf of the three of us. So we were kind of hedging our bets in all directions. Yeah. Yeah, that's so cool. So Andy's the performer. Yeah. Your mom. Hmm. Your Keef is going to keep them grounded. Tracy, that was like, it's like an idol when the parents bring the kid on and then the parents get on.
So then at what point then do you guys say, hey, you know, we make some pretty snazzy vids too. Do you guys wanna maybe hire us for that? We weren't hired for that, interestingly. We had been doing it. Like we'd even made a few joke raps. Thank you very much. The best.
It just killed me. And you basically started the S&L Digital Shorts. They'd never done anything like that. Now they do it all the time. Well, McKay had done it. McKay, yeah. Oh, McKay did it. That's right.
That's right. Forgive me. And Smigel? Much less frequently. But his were great, obviously. TV Funhouse and all that. Yeah. McKay did them with like Pat, what's his name, and a bunch of those dudes.
I forget that guy's name. Anyway, but yes, but those guys had done them, but they were more esoteric, if you will. Like they were kind of off the wall and kind of, you guys kind of were able to hone in on stuff. Obviously McKay's a legend, so I'm not disparaging him. And anyway, the guy's an absolute giant. But you guys came in, we're doing something different, and you really...
I remember that night that... that Lazy Sunday came out. I think it was the last show before Christmas, am I right? Yeah, Christmas show, our first season. Yeah, I know it. It's insane. I'd like to see you maybe just have a bit of a weed problem in the future, just to knock down your memory a little bit.
Yeah. But I remember even just the reaction in the building, Andy, and you, to walk us through that, because it was palpable. That thing, they aired that thing, and it was just like electricity. Everybody went like, there was pre-Lazy Sunday, and there was post-Lazy Sunday.
I'm serious. But tell people what Lazy Sunday is. Yeah, yeah. Lazy Sunday was our first hashtag comedy rap that we aired on the show. Right. It was me and Parnell, the great Chris Parnell. Chris Parnell. Who everyone on Earth loves.
The greatest, nicest guy in the world. And, you know, we had done, like I said, we had done stuff on our own like that for like, thelonelyisland.com. And like, tried to get it put on other websites that had bandwidth for streaming before YouTube existed. But you guys emerged at the same time YouTube was created, which was phenomenal. Yeah, and it was very fortuitous for us
where it was like, oh, YouTube became a thing at the moment we had this song people wanted to share. Yeah. And we will be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So guys, if you're anything like me, you've caught yourself at some point in your life
comparing your life to other people, which is really, really unhealthy. And social media plays a huge part of that. You know, this quote I've always loved by Theodore Roosevelt, like by the way, I can't believe I'm quoting Theodore Roosevelt, but comparison is the thief of joy. And so it's really easy to get caught up in today's society with social media and everything going on to go,
why don't I look like that? Why don't I have that? Why don't I do this? And I've caught myself doing that throughout the years and it's really unhealthy. It's not a good thing and it needs to be addressed in your own life. And so that's what I do.
I go to therapy and I talk about stuff if that particular issue comes up about comparing. Because comparing yourself to others, total joy killer. It's so easy to look at someone's social media and think they've got it all figured out. But the truth is everyone's got their own stuff going on behind the scenes that you can't see, right? So therapy can help you focus on what you want
instead of what others have, so you can start living your best life. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Stop comparing and start focusing with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartList today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. SmartList gets support from ZipRecruiter. Summertime's here and all those seasonal gigs are opening up, you know, stuff like Mule Wrangling and running those drama camps. The thing is, there's a real need for people
with those specific skills, but they can be kind of hard to come by, you know? Whether you're hiring for one of those roles or any other role, how do you find top talent before the competition gets to them? ZipRecruiter. And right now you can try ZipRecruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist.
ZipRecruiter's got this powerful matching technology that really digs in to find you top-notch talent for roles you're looking to fill. As soon as you post your job, ZipRecruiter's smart technology shows you the qualified peeps that are a perfect fit. Gear up for summer with ZipRecruiter's high-speed hiring tools. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try ZipRecruiter for free.
ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. We get support from State Farm. For the love of Pete! Something you might say when your car gets damaged. But that won't get you the help you need for your car. Screaming out to Pete?
That's not going to do anything. What you should really say is something that can actually help. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. For help, filing your claim 24-7. When things get complicated and you need ways to get help, State Farm gives you options there too. Maybe you like to handle things in person or on the phone with your local agent. Or you prefer to do it on statefarm.com or their award-winning app.
State Farm lets you do things your way. With a State Farm agent, you know someone is there to help protect your future by helping you choose the coverage you need. With so many coverage options, it feels good knowing you can find what fits for you. Whether it's on the phone, online, or on the award-winning State Farm mobile app, however you choose, like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. [♪ music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music You wrote it, or you submitted it on a Wednesday, just at the table read? How did you, did you go to Shoemaker and those guys?
Like how did that come about? Keev and Yoram had done one on their own, which was an idea we'd had for a while. I left town to do some general meetings. Yeah, sure, sure. The best part of our business. You had a kingdom to fill. And how are you?
How are you? I don't know why I'm here. What would you like to do next, Mr. The best part of our business. You had a kingdom. And how are you? How are you? I don't know why I'm here. What would you like to do next, Mr. Samberg? I mean, obviously we're familiar with your work. Sure. Not gonna say any of it because we're not. Right? For Tracy, that's how all those general meetings in Hollywood go.
Well, you leave everyone thinking like, I'm about to make 12 movies in a row and then you never Anyways they made a little music video thing called Bing Bong Brothers Which was a send-up of this song by the yin-yang twins and we showed it to Shoemaker and Higgins and they were like This is great. But we have so much cast right now our first season I think we had like 17 or 18 cast members Wow, and they were like if you can do stuff like this, but put the cast in it, right? but we have so much cast right now. Our first season I think we had like 17 or 18 cast members. Wow. And they were like, if you can do stuff like this but put the cast in it,
you don't even have to ask our permission, just go shoot something and if it's good, then we can try and use it at dress to change sets. Because we always need pre-tape pieces to change over sets during commercial breaks and stuff is not enough always. And it can save other people's live sketches if you have a pre-tape. Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right, right. That was kind of honestly why they were pushing us to do it. And so then we did one that was based on an idea Forte had had called Lettuce, where it's just me and him dramatically having a conversation and taking huge bites out of heads of lettuce on the stoop. And that was the first one that aired.
Yes. That's so good. Just the most forte shit ever. I forgot about that. I'm just gonna be so serious. Yeah, that's his entire life. And then we did another one that was basically that one again, called Peyote, that didn't air until the end of that season. And then the third one we that was basically that one again Called peyote that didn't air till the end of that season and then the third one we shot was lazy Sunday, which was a
Dork rap about me and Parnell having a lazy Sunday going to see the Chronicles of Narnia So good how big can I but I mean this sounds such a cheesy fan question because I am and we are, but like, it's so dumb, so just bear with me, and I'm sure you've been asked this a million times. How did you- Is show business hard? It's so hard. No, is, you know, dick in the box.
Like all of them became so huge on their own. How did you, I would ask the same question to a musician. How did you come up with them? Is it like, are you at home in the shower thinking of the most bizarre, funny shit? Or is it like, do you come up with a song first and then you're like, let's do a video? Or like, how does it all happen?
It's different every time. So like, Lazy Sunday was very similar to a song Keev and Yoram had done before we were on SNL called The Heist, which was about them talking about chamomile tea and stuff. So it was totally very like, this is our version of that, which now we feel slightly guilty about
because everyone and their mom has done that and still some are doing it. And feels a little like, okay, we get it. And then like Dick in a Box was Timberlake hosted and was like, we were chatting with him in our office and sort of realized we all had come up on the same music in the early 90s, like that early 90s R&B and that we loved that style.
And he was obviously capable of singing it really, really well. The little half glasses, the little Barry Gibb glasses are just... Yeah, exactly. Sorry, keep going. Which, you know, I look back at it now, I'm like, oh, this is like almost fully back in style. Yeah.
But Andy, so, but I kind of want to get back into, because there was that, like I said before, there was that moment, sort of pre and post Lazy Sunday. And I just remember as soon as that hits and it goes crazy, like one of the first sort of viral videos, if you will, really, all of a sudden, it's like you guys are at Paramount, right? All of a sudden, you're at Brad Gray's office, you're making Hot Rod, and you've got a movie deal, and you've got all that. Like, it just went like that.
Yes. Right? Am I right about that? Some would argue too fast. Really? No. Yeah. Not me. I mean, Hot Rod, you know all about because you're in it, and you're fantastic in it, and we were so grateful you did it. Yes.
No. Yes. I actually do remember, you know what? I do remember, Andy, funny you say it too fast, I remember one day going to Paramount to meet Lorne one of the off weeks, and you guys were at the Broadway video office, do you remember that? You guys were writing?
Rewriting it, yeah. And you were rewriting it. And I remember that you, Keith, and you were being in the room. And I was like, how's it going? You guys have your laptops. And you were so, you guys were so stressed out. You're like, I don't know if we're gonna be able to do this.
Because it was like really quick. And they're like, great, here's a movie, rewrite it and we start shooting July 1st. Yeah. I mean, we were psyched, and we knew that it was a window that had opened and you gotta go through it, but it was also like... I mean, I had been on someone's desk
like a year and a half before that, dreaming of this happening, and then all of a sudden it's like, boom! And it's happening so fast. This is the thing I've really thought about more as we've gotten older is It never occurred to me how anyone else was perceiving us because we were so in it and like shot out of a cannon And now I'm like oh
If that happened to someone now, I'd be like who the fuck are these guys? What did they do to get this? One song thing? Exactly. Exactly. Your proof of concept though was already just like right there and you'd already been stamped and embraced by the SNL pedigree and embraced by the exact demo, Paramount's asking you guys to hit.
So it was like, I'm sure you guys had, you weren't paralyzed with fear, but sort of knowing you're going into new ground. Yes, also we were still like, not just actually young, but like young in the industry. So for us, we still had the like, no man, we're gonna make it this. And like, no shade, because I love this movie.
They wanted Dodgeball, and we wanted like, Wet Hot American Summer. And I think Hot Rod ended up somewhere in between. Had Akiva and Norma directed anything other than the digital shorts at that point? No. Right. But you know, we had shot,
Kiva directed basically everything we had done for five straight years leading up to that. Like we moved to LA together and just started shooting stuff because we both went to film school. And that was the plan. Like we're just gonna keep shooting stuff and show people why we're funny and not try to tell them. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's funny, I was talking about photos just before about finding the arrested thing. I was also found, I have a photo weirdly in a silver, it looks like a really fancy frame, and it's on the set of Hot Rod. I just saw it, and it's Keev talking to me in this, and he's being really serious, and I'm being really serious, and I'm like, we're on the set of Hot Rod. I just saw it, and it's Keev talking to me in this, and he's being really serious, and I'm being really serious, and I'm like, we're on the set of Hot Rod, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like, it couldn't be more serious. He's like, say babe three more times. Yeah, exactly. Andy, where does the film school and filmmaking kind of desire for you live currently? Or is it just sort of just acting now, or do you still kind of thirst for making stuff?
Well, I mean, I'm basically a producer on almost everything I do. And I feel like I'm a creative producer, if that's a thing. For sure. And it's not for everyone. Andy, explain for Tracy what the difference is. Like a hardcore producer-producer is the person who's actually talking to all the production heads
and putting together a movie or a show and dealing with the studio or network on a daily basis. And it's a grind and it's a specific skill set and it's a specific personality type that is really valuable and rare to find someone that's great at it. And then for me, I'm like, I am heavily involved in the creative decisions
of everything I'm in basically, if whoever I'm working with is amenable. But like, that to me is, that was my role with the guys, with Keev and Yoram, so that's kinda how I developed. You were on the producing track as opposed to the directing track in film school, yeah? I mean, I was technically directing, but I didn't enjoy it because it's just so much multitasking
and I also wanted to be acting in stuff. I mean, I don't know, I am blown away by people like yourself that can act in it while directing. That to me is such a head fuck. I don't know how to do that. Just try it once, you'll see, oh, it's pretty efficient. It's a... Well, let me ask you this, not to get too granular,
but the one thing that worries me more than anything is giving notes to the actors I'm in a scene with. Like, I have this insecurity as soon as I'm like, can you do it more like this? And they're like, fuck you, bitch. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, you do it more. You do it more like this.
I know what it's gonna be. It is true. It is a certain amount of unstated arrogance and hubris to actually be giving a note to somebody you're on an equal play field with. I hear you on that for sure. I have no explanation for that aside from the kindness of the person that's listening to the note. Especially like what if you're doing like romance stuff? Right. Yeah.
I feel like I wasn't believing that you like me enough. Right. Be more into it. Yeah. And that's how you met your wife, right? Be more into it. Okay, on this tick, marry me. Right. I want to feel from your kiss that we should be married. Here we go. Still rolling. Rick, you're just like face to face and they're like sitting there and you keep going, no, more. No, I don't buy it. Again, no, close deeper.
But you do, but yeah, but you do, because TV is sort of a writer's medium, you do end up by default kind of directing, especially in comedy, kind of directing anyway, right? And so it's pretty, it's directing adjacent. Yes, we did eight seasons of Brooklyn Nine-Nine, for example, and I was a producer on that. And as the show went on, I would definitely be on set
as a producer, not just an actor, a lot creatively. And making sure scenes were working and being a big part of editing with Dan Gore and knowing like we're gonna need like some alts on the end of this scene because this isn't playing. You can just feel it in the room. It's not landing right. And then you pow wow and you pitch a couple extra jokes
and then you have each cast member try a different thing and then you know you have options and blah, blah, blah. And you're hiring the directors. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you worked with the great Dan Gore and obviously you had a lot of great comedic minds on that show as well with the great Mike Schur,
who we all adore, and Phil and Chris as well. Yeah, they shot the pilot. They shot the pilot. So you had a pretty, that was like a fucking hall of Fame team. I got to rewatch it during the pandemic with my oldest unarchie. He was there and able to super into it. We ended up watching it all through.
So, so, so funny. And, you know, one of the through lines we mentioned right at the top, one of the through lines in what you do so well, and you do so many things so well, but you always... There's oftentimes you incorporate music into what you do. And I kind of wanted to understand a little bit about like what your history is with music. Did you study music as a kid?
First of all, you got a great voice, you got great timing. Um... it's true. So, how do you come by it? Um, well, thanks. I grew up in a house that music was always playing and me and one of my two sisters were both kind of just always obsessed with music. I don't know exactly why.
I think I had a father who had a great appreciation of it, had a big record collection. And then when I hit junior high and high school, I pretty much just went to the record store all the time. I grew up in Berkeley, California, where the first Amiga music was built. And I was at Amiga Records in high school two or three times a week, just DITC,
which is digging through the gates. They do vinyl again, right? They sell, they're still in business, they sell vinyl. Yeah, apparently vinyl has made a massive resurgence. Yeah. Massive. They do vinyl again, right? Mm-hmm. They sell, they're still in business, they sell vinyl. Yeah, apparently vinyl has made a massive resurgence. Yeah. Massive. Yeah, it's cool. Wait, so I wanna talk more about that.
So you grew up in the Bay Area, you grew up around music, what kind of music did your dad listen to and then you listened to, and what kind of would you, did you gravitate towards a specific genre out of Miba Records? Ah, yeah.
Take those in order, please You can go backwards it was definitely all kinds of music I mean I think a lot of people that grew up in the Bay Area would say the same thing which is music is just a big part of the culture there for no matter who you are as a kid there and so like there were definitely people who were like we're punks and we listen to punk and like we're backpackers and we listen to hip
hop. But most people were like, I listen to 12 genres of music and I love the right right right of all of them. And we were certainly that and my friend group was that where we'd be like super into dancehall and reggae but also super into contemporary hip hop and old hip hop and old funk soul because of hip hop because we chased down the samples from our favorite hip hop songs. But also I love Bob Dylan and grew up listening to Bob Dylan and wore my mom's purple scarf
to try and look like Bob Dylan in high school. That's great. But you were so adept at hip hop and you guys were kind of like the West Coast comedy Beastie Boys. Well that's high praise. Yeah, oh nice Will. It's true.
Very nice. It is true. That's totally true. It's totally true and you were able to do it in such an authentic way too because there are a lot of like sort of white boys from Berkeley who couldn't pull it off and you guys just made it work because you were actually good at it. And God what did I just you know what I saw the other day was one of the video from Bash Brothers, the thing you guys did about the Oakland days.
Have you ever seen that you guys? And I can't believe that you pulled it off. What is it? You play Jose Kinseko, Keev plays Mark McGuire and then they do this rap about being on steroids and fucking how small their balls are. And I'm thinking like... Yeah, me and Keev did as kind of just like a side project
because Yoram was unavailable, so we didn't want to do a proper Lonely Island album without him. Concept album. And then we did like a visual poem, kind of like Lemonade, and very quietly released it on Netflix. And it's Keev is Mark McGuire and I'm Jose Conceco and the whole thing is an album of if the two of them had made a rap record
in the late 80s during their heyday, what would it have sounded like? I remember being totally fanning out, being so excited and kind of nervous. Sudeikis and I, we were on like a lunch break while we were doing one of the horrible bosses and we were in the valley. And he's like, oh, you know, the guys,
they rented a house down here. They're recording one of their albums. And he took me over there and it was like noon or something. And we walked in, I think you guys are recording Turtleneck and Chain maybe, right? Yeah. And- Turtleneck and Chain.
Yeah. And- That's so good. And I was like, where's Andy? They're like, oh, he's still sleeping. I was like, damn right. Yeah, exactly. They had rented like this colonial style mansion in Encino.
The monstrosity. Yeah, and they just set it up, just like a rock band would, you know, you record in a mansion, but it's usually in the Cotswolds, you know. But this was like off Louise Drive in Encino. But it was pretty awesome to see that. Those summers were so fun. Yeah.
And everyone, the coolest thing about it was how much space we had, and we just put out, like, everyone in comedy come over. That's really cool. And it really happened. Like we have photos of so many of the people that are just the biggest names in comedy now that swung by, because they were like,
hey, I heard those lonely guys have this stupid house in Encino. Oh, that's great. Right? And we would just drink and have fun and then record songs and knew we were banking them for the next season of SNL. That's so cool.
That's so cool. Do you guys ever talk about getting together and doing another one of those house rentals and just putting down another record? It's tough now because we have kids. Well, they can be in it. Yeah, they can write them in. I don't know that we'll do another house rental ever
unless it's like a compound for all the kids to run around in. Do that. Right. But I definitely think we're gonna try and make more music. I don't think we're done. Look how young your face is.
Kids having kids. Yeah. That's unbelievable. It is funny though, like I always, because Andy, you're younger than I am and then we are, because the three of us are basically the same age. Jason's older, obviously, is that.
No, just a lot older, but. How old a fellow are you, Andy? I'm 45. Oh, good for you. Yeah. Youngin'. And so now that, like, you've got like, I'll Google it.
54. You just seem so young. Oh, really? 53, well, 53. 53, we're 53. You're the coolest. But I have a new penis. did I tell you guys that? Oh, is that true? Yeah, you buried the leaf. Oh, you did it Amazon fucking crazy, right?
But anyway, sorry, yeah, yeah, yeah We're like rehydrate it. It's like a sea monkey. Well, no, this one's full of moisture. The old one was Spritz bottle I had a fucking Hudson sprayer. It's just enough. So you've got a, you went out and got yourself a new one that you're not gonna use? Yeah. Why don't you just keep not using the old one?
Can we get a time check on how long it was since the last dick joke? Can we? I just want to point out I didn't start that one. That was not me, I was not the instigator. I jumped right in. How hard is it for you to not talk about dicks? Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha and when you get home. A fire starts when they decide to make a snack. Do your kids know who to call? Do they know how to say Alexa, call for help? That's all they need to do to be connected
to a dedicated emergency response agent faster than industry standards. Real stories show us time and again, immediate action and information is crucial. Alexa Emergency Assist arms urgent response agents with critical information about you and your family. Additionally, your pre-saved emergency contacts are notified when you call for help and when the call ends.
For me, I got so excited when I got it in the mail, I opened it up, I put it on the kitchen island right in the center, because the kitchen's kind of the center of our house, and the comfort and security knowing that the device is sitting in the kitchen, which is the central part of the house, is such a peace of mind thing.
I love knowing it's there, I love having it set up, ready to go, in the case of any emergency. And it's got all of our contacts in there, and Scotty knows it's there, and everybody who's in our lives know it's right there on the center island in our kitchen, ready to use. So it's really kind of a wonderful thing.
It makes you sleep better at night, knowing that it's there. So for that added layer of protection for your family, property, and even your pets, trust in the peace of mind that only Alexa Emergency Assist can provide. Learn more and subscribe at www.amazon.com slash Alexa Assist. We get support from Helix. Everybody knows we have Helix mattresses
and we use them all the time. Why do we use them? Because they work. They are so comfortable, they're so relaxing, they put me to sleep immediately, my head hits the pillow on the mattress. It's fantastic. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress
than by sleeping on it in your own home. That's why they offer a 100 night trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty. So how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Well, their team created a Helix sleep quiz to help you find your perfect mattress in under two minutes. And your mattress is shipped straight to your door
free of charge. I took the quiz and of course, as I mentioned, I got the Dusk Lux because I wanted the perfect night's sleep for me and my body and the way I sleep and the temperature I run. I run a little hotter, I like it cool. So it's actually perfect for me. It's like they read my mind. Helix is offering up to 30% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com. That's helixsleep.com. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With Helix, better sleep starts now. Smartless is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your Sleep starts now. SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar. Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds,
new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audiobooks, podcasts, and originals that members can listen to all they want with more added all the time. Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time. There's more to imagine when you listen. I've
been listening to Dune. Why? Because I love it. I love the movie so much I was like I actually want to go back and I've never read the book I've never heard the book I should say and so it's really cool they have all these people narrating it different different characters it's really cool to have all these people narrating it, different characters. It's really cool, and if you're a fan of Dune and Arrakis, I'm learning about Arrakis. And Frank Herbert, who wrote it, it's much more descriptive than the movie,
even though the movie's fantastic. But to hear all the words and how he describes everything, and you go, oh yeah, I remember that. It's really, really cool. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days.
Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. Hey, smartless crew. I've been drinking AG1 since 2020.
It's become my daily go-to foundational nutrition supplement. Really, I trust AG1 because it's not just about what's in it, but what's not. Catch my drift? AG1 is rigorously tested for 950 impurities way beyond the industry norm. Seriously, it's a game changer for me. I feel the difference daily. What I love about it is it's so easy. You can make a smoothie and just dump it in
with all the other stuff in your smoothie, or you can just mix it with water and take it on the go, and your body's getting all the vitamins and minerals that you could possibly need. Instead of taking a bunch of supplements and buying all that healthy food that you'd have to eat, it's just AG1 all in one drink. Now, let's get into the good stuff.
Why AG1? It's a powerhouse for major body systems with ingredients like vitamin C and zinc, which helps me make my immune health in tip-top shape. AG1 is the supplement I trust to provide the support my body needs daily, and that's why they've been a partner for so long. If you take just one thing, let it be AG1.
Try AG1 and get a free one-year supply of vitamin D3K2 and five free AG1 travel packs with your first purchase. Go to drinkag1.com slash smart list so they know we sent you. That's drinkag1.com slash smart list. Check it out. All right, back to the show. Andy, I wanna talk to you about growing, no, when you were a kid, because I read this
thing where you wrote a letter to your eight-year-old self, which, what was that about? And were you into comedy at such a young age that you knew that you wanted to do it even at eight years old? Yes. I mean, I have said forever, and it's really genuinely true that at eight I just said that I wanted to be on SNL specifically. Oh my God, that's great. I love that.
I used to, I was into WWF Wrestling, and there was that show called Saturday Night's Main Event, which was on once a month. We don't need to tell Tracy about that one, huh? Yeah. I didn't know what Saturday Yep Missed it
First reference we haven't had to explain So speaking to the demo she's quietly nodding there in Chicago right continue and She's saying continue. Got it. Oh my God. But yeah, so the nights that it wasn't on was SNL. So I found it by accident as a kid and watched it. And it was, you know, love its carvy era.
And you wrote a letter saying, doing like what, of goals or something? Oh no, I think it was like a school assignment where it was like fill in the blank thing and it was like when I am older I will be and I was like a comedian obviously. Was there ever a moment where it got emotional for you on Saturday Night Live, either your first performance or your last one or?
Oh my God, the whole time. Yeah, I'll bet. The feeling of I'm living inside of actual dreams I've had. Yeah. And now I'm friends with people that I would meet in my dreams. Right. That were cast members on the show
and then I got on the show and they were still working there because we watched every episode. It was my absolute obsession. That's so great. And then now I'm like, oh yeah, now I just like chat with them whenever. And you're part of that fraternity now of people who are on it, and it is a very sort of tight knit, no matter, it's kind of like a... You see each other, you can give a nod or you can say hey,
because it's the smallest demo, right? Like, I mean, it's just the tiniest percentage of people who've ever been cast members in the show. Yes. Was it what you thought it would be? Or, I mean, answer that just the tiniest percentage of people who've ever been cast members in the show. Yeah. Was it what you thought it would be? Or, I mean, answer that, but then also, what was the most surprising part of it, or the part that really kind of floored you,
like that you didn't really imagine? I think it was similar to what I was expecting, because I had read so much about it, but the thing I wasn't expecting was for it, and I genuinely mean this, for it to go so well for us. The whole cast. Having watched it and having seen how hard it is, especially in terms of how quickly,
because the thing about SNL generally, unless you're one of 10 people, is you have to ingratiate yourself to the SNL generally, unless you're like one of 10 people, is you have to like ingratiate yourself to the SNL audience and give them time and space to figure out what you do that is funny and why. Yeah, it's very smart of you, yeah, for sure. And so for us, speaking to what we were just talking about with Lazy Sunday, that was a crazy shortcut
to the path I thought we were on. Like when Lazy Sunday aired, Will, you asked, and I didn't answer it, what was it like when you guys were in the studio when that aired? We were not thinking like, we did it! We were just like, oh, we got something on. I'm so relieved we're not gonna get fired. Because it was the world halfway into our first season.
And then when did it start to dawn on you that, oh, this thing caught on? Like, was it the next day when you woke up from the after party, like you saw online that there was some traffic about it? Yes. And the press part of it. Like, we immediately were, like, in touch with the NBC PR people.
Which, I was like, oh, I don't know anything about this world. And they're like, hey, New York Times wants to talk to you. You guys free right now? We were just like, okay. Geez, sure. About what? We sure are. But you know, everybody always talks to you about those shorts,
but I loved tons of stuff that you did, but I loved the impressions you did. Mark Zuckerberg, Nick Cage, Mark Wahlberg, Hugh Jackman. Was there a celebrity of somebody you did that you heard from about any of your impressions? I mean, the one that was the most gratifying was Cage for me. Nick Cage?
Because he came on and did it with me. Yes, I remember that. And the Cage thing, and he was so cool about it and he did not have to be, because we were like, doing a psychotic character and saying he was Nick Cage. You know what I mean? It was like, and I was, and still am, and we all are a massive fan of Nick Cage,
and I've seen so many of his movies, and that's how it ended up being something I could do, because I was like, I've seen him talk so much. Yeah, yeah. Well, that's the thing, too, is that you made... You didn't make fun of, but you poked fun at certain elements, but you never punched down. It was always people who were massive,
whether it was Nick Cage, you did... Wahlberg came on, I remember he came on as well, as you were doing, say hello to your mother for me. Like, again, you're punching up, like, you're making a joke because he's such a massive movie star, right? Yes. And by the way, that way, when you're on SNL, this is the thing I always think about, because I'm like, I never got into comedy
to do impressions or make fun of anyone. Obviously amongst my friends, we'll talk shit about literally anything. And anybody. But when you're on the show, impressions are such a, it's such currency, right? And you know it plays, and you know it'll get on,
and you're just desperately trying to get on. So if you do one that works and everyone's laughing at, it's hard to be like, no, I'm not gonna do that. I don't feel good about it morally. Did you have to do it for your audition? Did you have to do impressions? Yes. Yeah? For your audition, Did you have to do impressions? Yes. Yeah.
For your audition, they asked you to do characters and impressions. And when I got asked, by the way, I had been doing standup, but I had no impressions or characters. So we wrote them all leading up to the audition. Oh wow. What was your go-to impression at that time?
Honestly, by chance, it was Fallon because I did the Temp Fallon voice on the movie awards for the storyboards of the pre-tape we wrote. And then Jimmy, who is the nicest and was so nice to us, he really helped put us on. But he heard me in the Temp VO of the animatic, which is the storyboards of whatever it was, and it was me being like, oh my god, we gotta go, Batman.
And he was like, who's doing my voice? Oh my god, it's so funny. And so they were like, even Higgins was like, hey, when you audition, you should do Jimmy. And I was like, oh. Really? So I did Jimmy Fallon at a funeral. But he was like, oh my god, I'm so sad.
At a funeral is really funny. Oh my god, McClay and thanks. And they're like, okay. This guy can't do impressions. I love that. I love that so much. So wait, so tell me about how, you know, I did that little thing with you, the Maya Rudolph show. And you made me pee in my pants. We had fun, Sean. Tell me about how, you know, I did that little thing with you, the Maya Rudolph show. And you made me pee in my pants.
So. We had fun, Sean. Oh my God, I laughed so hard with you. I was crying laughing. And so many bits came out of that. But you told me about your wife, and you're like, you know, you're a musician, Sean. My wife plays the harp and she sings.
I'm like, oh, who's your wife? And Joanne, as you told me, Joanne is, and I downloaded her album, and I was like, oh, who's your wife? And Joanne, as you told me, Joanne is, and I downloaded her album and I was like, oh my God, this woman's amazing. I fell in love with her right away. Do you guys work on music stuff together? Do you check in with her? How does that work?
We don't work on music together because, yeah. Mine's pretend and hers is arguably amongst the best ever, in my opinion. She's fantastic. Tell me about her. What is it? Does she play in an orchestra? No, no. Her name's Joanna Newsom. She's a singer-songwriter who plays harp and piano and sings at the same time. Yeah, Jay, you would love, would love it. She's so good. I'm such a fan. You know I'm a fan. Yes.
I mean, we met because I was at her concert with Fred and our friend, Matt Murray, because I was obsessed with her music. Is that true? Yeah. You, Fred and the Panther. Yeah. Wait, who's the Panther? Our writer friend, Matt Murray.
I forget who dubbed him the Panther, maybe like Spivey or someone. Somebody like that. Or Dratch possibly, that he would sit in the corner quietly and then... Yeah, when somebody goes like, oh, that's the Panther, you're like, that's the Panther. But because he would lay in the cut and wait and then strike with his joke that would kill everybody after... So funny.
Yeah. So you're at Joanna's concert and you wiggle your way backstage as a creepy fan and And and somehow get her your number No, it wasn't she we just met and hung out all together that night just friendly style but Fred had met her and her friends at a at a music festival that he had been at I guess in the summer previous and and her and her friends at a music festival that he had been at, I guess, in the summer previous. And it just worked out. Like, I had been listening to her albums for years and been to her show before even. But when I met her, it turned out she and her siblings had watched Lonely Island stuff, so it was very comfortable and not as creepy as I was.
I love that. And then you fell in love and you made babies and here we are. Whoa, whoa. You don't wanna talk about the lovely stuff. Shawn. How they make babies. You wanna talk about, hey, did anybody ever forget a line during a live taping of, tell me, could you ever not read. Oh, you know I love that. Could you ever not read the cards, Andy?
I love those stories. Did someone ever get in your way between you and the cards? You know, I love those stories. Did someone ever get in your way between you and the carts? You know, I love that. If you have a biggest flub SNL story, I live for them. But if you don't, that's fine. I mean, I do have one, but it's not that crazy. No? Okay, well what is it?
I was standing underneath the main part of the bleachers, like the main walk that you do towards the main stage. And Seinfeld was on, I think he did really with Seth on update. And he stopped and started talking to me and I was like, holy shit. So we were just chatting and I was like, oh yeah, Seinfeld, and I was like, yeah, this and that.
And then I was like, I looked up at, you know, they have monitors all backstage showing you what's airing. And I just like casually look up and I was like, yeah, this and that. And then I was like, I looked up at, they have monitors all backstage showing you what's airing. And I just casually look up and I'm like, oh, I'm in this sketch and it just started. Oh my God, no way. I was like, I'm so sorry, and just took off running. And it was a courtroom sketch.
I missed getting on before it started. They stopped me and said, no! Because I was going to try and run on. Totally, by fortune's fucking hell, who knows? I had had one line at the top of the sketch and they had cut it between dress and air and no one had told me. So I actually didn't screw up the sketch,
but I did have my nightmare that I had every week that time working there and still now have where I'm backstage and I can't find the set. I can't find stage and I'm in a sketch and I can't get there and I see it on the monitor and it actually happened, but I got very lucky. Actors' Nightmare, I love very lucky. Actors Nightmare. I love those stories.
Wait, now Palm Springs is one of my favorite movies. I love that movie. When I saw it come out, I was like, oh, Andy's in a gay film. And then it wasn't gay at all. Another one? Bennett Barbekel's brother. So as you know, Bennett, who is part of our team, I'm gonna say hi.
It's his brother directed, as you know. Yes, I do. Love that movie. Loved hi, it's his brother, directed as you know. Yes, I do. Love that movie, loved you in it. So good. I love that movie. That movie is so good, and I tell anybody, it's one of my favorite films of the last 10 years,
so needs more attention, so unheralded. You're so funny and profoundly good and kind of sad, like it's the perfect blend of, I just love that movie. Thank you, I love it too. Any it's the perfect blend of, I just love that movie. Thank you. I love it too. Any truth to the sequel rumors, Palm Desert? No? Death Valley.
It's Palmdale. Palmdale. Indian Wells. And Andy, you have a new podcast with Seth Meyers called The Lonely Island, The Seth Meyers Podcast. Right? That's right. And how did it start? Are you excited?
Has it started? Tell us everything. Well, me and Keev and Yoram forever, especially during COVID, and we didn't jump on it like you smart guys, we're like, we should do one. It'll make it that we get to see each other and talk all the time.
We should do one where we talk about the digital shorts and every episode can be a digital short and what was going on in our lives and at SNL that week when we did the digital short. And then because we're us, we kind of just let it drift. And then Seth called us and was like, hey, I just had an idea. How would you guys feel about doing a podcast
where every episode is about one of the digital shorts and what was going on at the show that week, and I'll host it, and my team will organize it, and you guys just show up and do it? And I'll take half. Yeah. Yeah. And he'll take, yeah.
No, he's got his good 80%. But I mean, he's late night. No, but it's late night. And he's a good guy. Like when other people aren't around, he's nice to me. He's like, I love that. Why, we gotta check it out. It sounds like- That's so fun.
So that's coming on soon. What's it called? The Lonely Island and Seth Meyers podcast? Yeah, we debated that name Yeah, I guess I see why why cuz it rolls off the While to get that one, what sounds like a huge argument What's your favorite Andy what we I know it's, but what's your favorite digital short that you guys did? When it's all said and done. I love the boat one on the boat.
Thank you. I'm On A Boat I think is the biggest selling song we ever did. Is it really? Yeah. I'm On A Boat. What's your personal favorite? Double platinum or something stupid.
That's incredible. My favorite, if I had to just pick one out of thin air, probably Jack Sparrow with Michael Bolton. Yeah. Sure. And the reason I would give, and we do generally say this one, and the reason is because it's sort of a confluence
of all the ones. So it's like people who really love comedy ride for it. Like I've been told that like writers rooms have watched it all together and enjoyed it, which is the highest compliment. And then also it sounds pretty good and the video's big and slick and it feels like big business,
which is something else that we were able to pull off. That's really like big business. I would say my favorite personally, of the digital short, and I'm a, as you know, a massive fan of them all. And I embarrass you all the time because I just tell you all the time how much I love the, but Dear Sister. Oh, nice. That's good.
Dear Sister for me scratches and itch because it just keeps going. But it's got a real story to it. I love non-musical one too. I mean I guess it is still music. It's still kind of musical. It's not your original music, but it's musical. But there's something about it.
Yeah. Dear Sister was an idea that we had started shooting before we got SNL. Oh wow. Yeah, me and Yoram I think, and my friend Chester, Chester Tam. Because it's originally based on this moment from the end of an episode of that show, The O.C.,
which we loved. Yeah. Of course. Where the character, Marissa, shoots someone and it cranks into slo-mo and that song comes on and it's those slo-mo shots of everyone's face being shocked that it's happened and someone falls out of frame and you're like,
oh my God, what just happened? It's a slow reveal and I remember us being like, that was fucking good TV and what is that song? So then I was like, what do we do? We do the same thing over and over again and then make it go faster and faster. So we started doing it but but never even finished it. And then I love that that is one that you like, Will,
because for us that week it was like out of desperation, we said, oh man, let's just try that, and then we'll just write an ending for it. And we wrote like way more and actually ended up like. Well the cast, first of all, the cast, if you look at our paper is insane. So it's you and it's Shia LaBeouf and it's Wig and Sudeikis and Fred and Hader.
Like, it's a freaking murderer's row of cast. I loved our cast. Yeah. It was really fun to get to work with that group. Yeah, I did too. And you know what, Andy? I have to say how you looked forward to Saturday to work with that group. Yeah, I did too. And you know what, Andy, I have to say how you looked forward to Saturday Night Live as a kid,
I looked forward to your digital shorts watching Saturday Night Live in the same way. Yeah, every single week. And now it continues to other things, like when I saw you in Palm Springs, I was like, oh my God, another movie that Andy's doing. I just can't get enough of it. This has been life-affirming, frankly. I wasn't expecting it to be this nice.
It's true. It's true. Andy, it's totally true that you are one of... You truly are one of the good guys because you're, A, supernaturally funny. You can't help it. You have no choice. And, B, you're very generous and you're very sweet. And any success and all the success you have had and will continue to have, you have completely earned it. There's no hiding what you, anyway, so it's just awesome. I'm just psyched, I just think you're a great dude. And we're so grateful you came today,
so thank you for coming on our little show. Guys, we're industry staples. Yeah, yeah, sure. We're not going anywhere. We did it. We did it. We did it. Game over.
But also with that, the caveat being, you know, your next bomb, I'm gonna be the first there to say, you bombed. Well guess what? We didn't talk about the box office on Hot Rod. We just skimmed right past that. Oh, we didn't talk about that. Yeah, that's true.
You know when you set out to make a cult classic on a studio's dime? It's because I was in it. I'm box office boys at that. Not true. Andy, thank you, my friend. Thanks for being here. We appreciate it. We appreciate it.
Thank you guys. You're the greatest. Yeah, keep on keeping on. You are this. And let's just be friends now and hang out, Jason. It's done. It's done. You can't shake me now. We'll find a time and just do it. I'll put you guys in touch.
Please do. Yes, please. I will. Definitely will. Okay. And Sean. Love you. Love you, Sean. Bye, guys. I mean, when I say guys, I mean... See you, bud. Bop a booey. Bop a...
Fafafoo-hi. Fafafoo-fly. Wait, what's Bop a boo. Bop a fu high. Bop a flu fly. Wait, what's Bop a buoy? Gary Dillebate from Howard Stern. Oh yeah, Bop a buoy, that's right. Bop a buoy. So, keep it real up in the field, alright? I would love to.
I would. I would love to. So guys, that was Andy Samberg. Yes, he was fantastic. He's the greatest. The greatest, he created his own lane. And he's my new friend. Yeah, he's your new friend.
And he doesn't really, yeah, he's stuck with me now. He doesn't realize it yet, but it's gonna be a problem for him. He's the real deal, and as I said, again, at risk of embarrassing him, he is such a good guy and he totally deserves it. He's just one of the good dudes. Kind, sweet, yeah. For sure.
And everybody agrees, everybody can agree, that everybody loves Andy Samberg. Yeah, that's a good name for his TV show. Everybody loves Andy. Everybody can agree, and everybody agrees, that everybody loves Andy Samberg. There you go. That's a good tune. There you go. It's a good tune.
There you go. Yeah, he's extra special. I love everything he does. Always good and everything he does. Good guest. And I'm excited to hear their new podcast that those guys are doing with Seth because I love hearing how they put together each one of those digital shorts. I love that they're like, it was last minute, they needed something.
Yes, I love all that stuff. Right? I love that stuff. And I think he could, for the Lonely Island, for, last minute, they needed something. Yes, I love all that stuff. I love that stuff. And I think for the Lonely Island guys, they created this brand and this company and this thing that's really awesome and cool and stays like real smart and real funny always. What? No, I have nothing. But if I did have something, it would be... It would go like this.
It would go... It would reference Howard Stern and I would have something, it would be... It would go like this. It would go... It would reference Howard Stern, and I would say something like... Bye bye, Bowie! Bowie! Bye bye, Bowie! Bye bye, Bowie! Close enough. Smart.
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
Less. Smart. Less. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico and Michael Granteri. SmartLess. If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Nancy's love story could have been ripped right out of the pages of one of her own novels. She was a romance mystery writer who happens to be married to a chef.
But this story didn't end with a happily ever after. When I stepped into the kitchen, I could see that Chef Brophy was on the ground and I heard somebody say, call 911. As writers, we'd written our share of murder mysteries. So when suspicion turned to Dan's wife, Nancy, we weren't that surprised. The first person they'd look at would be the spouse.
We understand that's usually the way they do it. But we began to wonder, had Nancy gotten so wrapped up in her own novels... There are murders in all of the books. ...that she was playing them out in real life? Follow Happily Never After, Dan and Nancy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge all episodes of Happily Never After, Dan and Nancy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.